hot breath so how do you have leverage
in this business
these guys on social media who frankly
aren't even close to as funny as many of
my favorite comedians have all the
leverage they're making way more money
than people on tv now
because they have leverage they can say
hey i got eight million fans
and i can tell eight million people to
watch this show
how much is that worth to you nbc how
much is that worth to you netflix
it's worth real money if you're a really
funny comedian
but you only got a thousand followers on
instagram
you can only tell a thousand people come
to your show now nbc's got to do all the
work
and getting people come to the show if
i'm nbc
and this instagram comedian who
auditions
just as well as this 1 000 follower
comedian
did it's a no-brainer who i'm going to
pick
think about how much better you you are
going to have to be for that role
if you have no leverage in order to be
chosen you got to be
it's worth not telling eight million
people
for free
funny so is that your your whole game
was you want to get undeniably funny
first
that's first not everything comes from
that and you're always growing
and you were i loved your hustle with
that because you would actually
transcribe
like dave chappelle's specials you were
looking at the math yeah
of comedy or do you still take that same
approach in analyzing your sets now
it's more like the matrix now it's more
like neo you know like neil when he sees
the green [__]
like that's how it is when you watch
comedy now you're just like oh i see
what he did there okay back in the day
you didn't know how to see the matrix
right so you have to write it down and
really [__] translate what is he
doing here
how how is his premise and how does okay
like i was trying to understand the
language of comedy so now i understand a
language so
it's it's less like i don't even like
watching famous guys because i don't
want them to influence me but
if i do watch it it will just be like
okay this is really
it's more to inspire me to push it
further you know like
dave chappelle's recent special i love
the structure of it
so now i'm thinking about with specials
it's like it's got to be more than just
an hour of jokes there's got to be some
arc
yeah you know i mean it's got to be
something pulling this whole thing
together what is it
so now that's how i think about a
special because of him and you actually
funded your own special right yeah i
shot my own yeah and we've been
struggling to sell it man it's a perfect
example